and um let's pray as we open this up
father take charge of the answers
to the questions that would be asked in
Jesus name we pray
amen
there one other announcement I want to
make we do have an exhibit Booth that'll
be in the fellowship hall and also there
is a meal A light meal prepared for
those that like to stay I feel I failed
to share that for those that want to
stay for the meal after the question and
answer and there will be an exhibit
exhibit booth in the back in the
fellowship hall for you to gain
resources that you may have interest in
God bless you
oh
hit this mic on please I'm going to ask
the questions from my seat
all right Pastor yes
people ask why children have to die so
young
or why there is so much sickness in the
world how can we respond to them
Father in Heaven gives me wisdom to
answer according to your will in Jesus
name I pray amen
there's something called sin
when we think of sin we simply cannot
think of Sin from our point of view
we have to think of Sin from God's point
of view now Adventists teach
and the servant of the Lord has made it
clear
that part of Satan's rebellion was to
accuse God falsely
God's character
was he was mischaracterized by Satan
that's why some angels followed Satan in
his Rebellion now keep in mind Angels do
not know everything
because they are created beings
those who live in unfallen Worlds they
do not know everything because they are
created
in order to clear his name God has to
allow sin to take its course
so that the unfallen worlds and the
angels can see what a horrible thing
Sinners and can be absolutely convinced
that Satan was wrong there is a
quotation I don't call it to mine right
now but Ellen White says it was only at
the cross when angels in heaven saw what
Satan did to Christ that they finally
cut all ties of sympathy with him
which means that for 4 000 years there
were still some angels in heaven who
were sympathetic and who felt Satan had
been unfairly treated
sinless angels
now God has to fix that
you understand that's why we read I
think it's Colossians 1 20 or 21 that
Christ by his death reconciled all
things on earth and in heaven
because the Angels had to be reconciled
to God because some of them still felt
Satan had not been fairly treated
now in order for God to convince the
universe that he was right Satan was
wrong the universe had to see what the
course of sin does
it sort of reached a Peak at Calvary
when Angels saw what Satan did to God
in the last days
when the spirit of God is withdrawn
and the world goes into chaos
the universe will see finally the
terrible nature of sin and so God has to
allow some things to happen but the fact
that a child dies doesn't mean the child
is lost
are you with me sometimes death is a
blessing God Saves some people by taking
them
and so there's sickness for two reasons
because we live in a world of sin but
there's also sickness because we violate
the health laws
commandment six says now shall not kill
and we take that to mean only don't kill
other people it also means don't kill
yourself
by the way you eat
the way you drink the way you take care
of your body we kill ourselves
I heard someone say many years ago many
of us dig our Graves with our teeth and
so yes there's death for two reasons we
live in a world of sin but there's
another reason why there's so much death
and suffering we've lived in violation
of the laws of God an education page 99
paragraph two Ella white rights to
violate his law physical moral or mental
is to place oneself out of harmony with
the universe to introduce Discord
Anarchy and ruin
sin
as a general principle but also sin
because of individual Disobedience to
God
but every person God takes is not lost
actually there's a blessing for death in
Revelation 14 13. blessed are they that
die in the Lord from henceforth yes said
the spirit that they may rest from their
labors and their Works do follow them
when my brother died about 12 years ago
I didn't grieve because he died in the
Lord
in the when my mother died in 218 I
didn't grieve because she was a child of
God and she was safe 98 no more
suffering no more stumbling around
safe
all right question two
all right but one day sorry Pastor one
day there'll be no death
are you with me The Last Enemy that
shall be destroyed is death death and
hell will be cast Into the Fire
now you and I ought to look forward to
the day when there is no more death
because there will be no more sin
amen
Pastor Keith the Bible States in Exodus
25 18 and thou shall make two cherubims
of gold my question is who do the
cherubims represent the cherubim
represent Angelic beings that work with
God in the administration of the
universe and in executing the Plan of
Salvation now go in your Bibles to
Exodus 25 quickly I know you're eager to
get home and I won't be long but that's
a very very good question of I've never
heard it before
do you have Exodus 25
we read verse 10 11 17 and 18.
well let's read eight first and we
talked about it when I made a
presentation keep but don't touch
remember that
and let them make me a sanctuary verse 8
of Exodus 25 that I may dwell among them
and they shall make an ark of
wood verse 10. two cubits and a half
shall be the length thereof a cubit and
a half the breath thereof and a cubit
and a half the height thereof verse 11
and thou shall overlaid with pure gold
with them and without shalt thou overlay
and shall make upon it a crown of gold
around the mouth so we have this box now
verse 17 and thou shalt make a mercy
seat of pure gold two cubas and a half
shall be the length thereof a cubit and
a half the breath thereof and thou shalt
make two cherubims of gold of beaten
work shall thou make them in the two
ends of The Mercy Seat now notice the
expression of beaten work shall thou
make them now verse 19 and make one
cherub unto one end and the other cherub
on the other end even of The Mercy Seat
shall ye make the cherubims on the two
ends thereof now what the Bible is
telling us the Angels were made from the
same piece of gold from which The Mercy
Seat was made
uh you didn't get that my fault
here's a piece of gold God told Moses
beat that gold and make The Mercy Seat
now also using the same piece of
gold make the two cherubims
so the cherubins representing angels are
intimately connected with the Plan of
Salvation are you following me one on
either side of God and God sits in the
middle right above the mercy seat and so
the cherubim are Angelic beings that
represent uh powers that God created
principalities and Powers refer to
various levels of authority God made
them and they assist God in both the
administration of the universe and in
the Plan of Salvation Angels assist us
in resisting sin their sisters in
avoiding sin their sisters in
understanding the word of God because
when Daniel was given a vision in Daniel
8 he could not understand and in verse 6
in the Bible says and I heard a man's
voice between the banks of Uli which
called and said Gabriel make this man to
understand division so an angel was told
help Daniel understand so angels are
involved in helping us to understand
God's word the cherubim represent Mighty
angels that function right in the
presence of God and when God put Adam
and Eve out of the garden verse 24 of
Genesis 3 and he put at the east of the
Garden of Eden cherubimus and a flaming
sword which turned every way to keep the
way of the Tree of Life their mighty
mighty very high
ly placed Angelic beings all right
all right the next one is before God
gave the Ten Commandments he saved them
from slavery first
slaves of sin cannot walk in the law of
Liberty right is it true that we must
obey before we are saved or is it true
that we obey after we have been saved
from sin
both
now
John 3 16 says for god well go to First
John chapter three you go to First John
chapter three read verse 23 for me
First John 3 23. now I said both you
believe before you believe after or you
obeyed before you obey after either way
it's by the power of God do you have
first John chapter 3
verse 23. my King James people what does
that say and this is his Commandment
that we should want believe what
on the name of his Lord Jesus Christ now
this is his Commandment that we should
do what believe in Jesus
John 3 16 the same writer says for God
so loved the world that he gave his only
begotten son that whosoever believeth in
him should not perish this believing in
him is required by God God commands us
to believe we don't have to obey when we
believe we have obeyed
so there's an act of obedience and as a
result of that I mean God's God's power
then this God does what he does by
virtue of justification now when the
Publican came to the temple to worship
Luke 18 what did he say
God come on be merciful to me
he believed
in the in the savior
that's obedient
he was justified now he had to walk in
the way of the law
you have a big you see obedience is the
condition of salvation
keeping the Ten Commandments that occurs
after you've after you saved or
Justified because that's a holy standard
but there must be an expression of
obedience in the fact that you express
faith in Jesus that's an act of
obedience
all right next question
this may be supposed to tell me
yes
this may be along the same lines it says
God is love and does not change first
John 4 8 Malachi 3 6 Hebrews 13 8. does
he really love us more when we are
obedient or is it more accurate to say
that the obedient are more able to
accept God's constant love than the
Disobedience no God loves us more
let me ask you this
what nation was closest to God
yes Lord go to
I think it's Micah chapter go to Micah
chapter 3.
I think it's Micah 3.
Micah 3.
no Micah 6 3 tell me what that says
you have Micah 6
no no that's that's the wrong try Micah
3 verse 3.
that verse is escaping me sorry
no that's not okay okay it's a verse
that says the only have I known of all
families of the Earth
God tells the Israelites
you're the only one I know
of course he knows everybody else but he
wants to stress the special relationship
they had with him
he says thee only have I known of all
the families of the earth now go to
Exodus 19.
is very straightforward in Exodus 19 we
read for verse 4. now we may go to six
you have Exodus 19 verse 4 you have seen
what I did unto the Egyptians and how I
bear You On Eagle's Wings and brought
you unto myself whom did he bring
literally whom did he leave
the Egyptians all right now therefore if
he will obey my voice indeed and keep my
Covenant then he shall be unto me a
peculiar treasure unto me come on what
are the next few words above come on
mm-hmm
go to Deuteronomy
seven
read verse 6.
for thou are the holy people under the
law thy God keep within the law thy God
hath
go on to be a yes he chose them
to have a relationship with him No Other
Nation had
but other nations could choose to join
are you with me other nations could
choose to join the Israelites and become
Israelites by being a circumcised
God chose Israel
to have a relationship with him No Other
Nation had
yes
Bible commentary volume 5 page 1142
paragraph six
the believer May bear the testimony in
his life and character that God loves
the human agent who obeys his commands
as he loves Jesus
there's a greater deeper love for those
who obey
amen
let me ask you this how many disciples
did Jesus have
on very special occasions whom did he
take with him Peter over and over there
were closer to him the closest Family to
Jesus the family of Mary Martha and
Lazarus Ellen White writes Christ loves
all the Human family Christ blessed
those who sought his help he loves all
the Human family desire of 80 space 524
paragraph one but to some he's Bound by
peculiarly tender associations his heart
was knit by a strong bond of affection
to the family at Bethany and for one of
them his most wonderful miracle was
wrought he reserved his finest miracle
for the person's closest to him Mary
Martin Lazarus
now of Peter James and John who was
closest John when Christ was on the
cross dying he looked down and saw his
mother Christ had four brothers he gave
his mother to John
John was closest to him
there are degrees of closeness to God
in Exodus 34 when God told Moses and be
ready in the morning and come up in the
morning unto Mount Sinai and present
thyself there to me in the top of the
mount
no man shall come up with thee
neither let any man be found throughout
the mount Exodus 34 Verse 3 no one else
comes up only you
and if anyone had come up
The Seventh-Day Adventist Church
is closer to God
more dear to his heart
than any other church on the face of the
Earth
if you study prophecy
I know you gave me a half dead amen but
you're afraid to say amen I understand I
understand but I'll go to my grave
believing that because it's
prophetically biblically correct God has
always had a people closer to him than
any other people
that's right next question my pastor all
right
what do you say about one who does not
believe in Jesus as God but a prophet
Jesus was a prophet
he was a prophet all right
to believe Jesus is the prophet is to
believe the Bible
are you with me the Bible says it was
the prophet now go to Second Chronicles
20 read verse 20 for me
second chronicles 20 verse 20. you're
familiar with this verse read it for me
my King James people this is the last
opportunity you have
literally
do you have second chronicles
chapter 20.
verse 20.
uh-huh
yes
now listen here hear me oh
uh-huh
believe the Lord your God so shall you
be
uh-huh believe his Prophet so shall he
Prosper now
was Jesus a prophet and I'd like to tell
I speak respect I'd like to tell the
Jews and the Jews believed Jesus was a
prophet but not the savior
are you following me now I use one of
their books
in the Old Testament
one of their books that they recognized
second chronicles says
believe your Prophets
so shall you prosper
if you're a Jew
you accept the Old Testament the Old
Testament tells you believe your
prophets and you also say Jesus was a
prophet
but Jesus also said I am the savior
believe your Prophets
are you following me amen believe your
prophets he said he's a savior you
recognize him as a prophet it's in the
Old Testament believe him
the question is what is sin it was that
the question yes the next one is what is
sent the Bible says sin is a violation
of God's law
First John 3 verse 4 whosoever
committeth sin transgresseth also the
law for sin is the transgression of the
law by the law is meant the Ten
Commandments
mm-hmm amen that's it
any sin is in some way a violation of
God's Commandments
Because by the law is the knowledge of
sin
now the Bible says in Psalm 119 verse 96
I have seen an end of all Perfection but
thy commandment is exceeding broad
meaning every one of the ten is so deep
you cannot exhaust it
the many things we can do to commit
combat to break in uh Philippians 3
verse 17 to 19 the Bible talks of people
whose God is the belly
are you with me now that's violating
commandment one and two
in Ephesians chapter 5 verse 5 it talks
an idolatrous man who was a Covetous man
who is an idolater Covetous commandment
10 Idol is a commandment too
God's commandment is Broad
it covers the thinking
the speaking and the behavior
because sin affects this thinking the
speaking and the behavior
and sin arises where in the heart that's
exactly where God writes his law
right where sin puts out this head so
the law can cut it off
through faith in Christ
next question pastor
is the righteousness of the law
fulfilled in Us by getting better at
obeying or by us getting better at
accepting crisis perfect obedience how
is our spirit empowered obedience
savific we accept the perfect Obedience
of Christ through total and constant
surrender
steps of Christ speech 48 paragraph 1
through the right exercise of the will
an entire change may be made in your
life by yielding up the will to Christ
you Ally yourself with the power that is
above all principalities and Powers you
will have strength from above to keep
you steadfast and thus through constant
surrender to Christ
you will be enabled to live the new life
even the life of faith we live out the
obedient Life of Christ listen to Paul I
am crucified with Christ nevertheless I
live yet not I but Christ liveth in me
and this is literal even though we can't
understand it and so Jesus says John 15
verse 4 abide in me and I in you as the
branch cannot bear fruit of itself
except it abide in the vine no more can
ye accept abide in me I am Divine hear
the branches he that abideth in me and I
in him the same bringeth forth much
fruit for without me he can do nothing
our obedient life is the outworking of
the life of Jesus Christ in us as we
remain surrendered
amen let's look at John 15 1-10
let's read from verse 4. there's a word
that pops up all the time let me see if
you can identify that word John 15
reading from verse 4.
have you found it
not yet some people still looking
oh
why didn't you say it
okay
well God bless you are we ready
abide in me and I in you as the branch
cannot bear fruit of itself except it
abide in the vine no more can ye accept
the abide in me five I am Divine hear
the branches he that abideth in me and I
in him the same bringeth forth much
fruit for without me you can do nothing
for six if a man abide not in me he is
cast forth at the branch and is withered
and Men gather them and cast them into
the fire and they burn if he abide in me
and my words abide in you he shall ask
what you will it shall be done unto you
hearing is my father glorified that ye
bear much fruit as the so shall he be my
disciples as the father have loved me so
love so do I love you continue ye in my
love if you keep my Commandments you
shall abide in my love even as I have
kept my father's Commandments and abide
in Islam what's the word
now
verse 10 has a word it doesn't have a
bite it has continued
but it's the same Hebrew word a Greek
word meno
what does Jesus trying to say abide
abide abide abide and by abide where
in him
so that he might work
through US literally now this was his
experience with the Father the father
would abide in Christ John 14 verse 10
believeth thou not that I am in the
father and the father in me the words
that I speak unto you I speak not of
myself but the father that dwelleth in
me
heed with the words this requires a
surrender of the
will the mind the will what's the will
that capacity to make a choice yes
I'm choosing to obey I'm choosing not to
obey give that to Christ
and then he replaces it with his will
and then his will controls yours and so
in the garden we see an example of that
father if thou be willing remove this
cup from me nevertheless not my will
we have two Wills Jesus says and the
fathers the father took the lead at the
request of geu is your will I surrender
to your will that's how we live the
Victorious Life
constant surrender to Christ
so we're one with him this is no joke we
are one with him
that calls for constant surrender
alamite rights desire of video speed 324
paragraph one
we may leave off many habits for a time
we may part company with Satan but
without a vital connection with God
through surrender of ourselves to him
Moment by moment we shall be overcome
without a continual communion a person a
continual communion we are at the mercy
of the enemy
and shall do his bidding
in the end
must surrender moment
by moment
because very often all the devil needs
is the right moment to ruin a life
and he's willing to wait 40 years
for that right moment
constant surrender and it's Christ
Living in you
so it's not you it's Christ not I but
Christ
next all right but by the way sorry and
Christ abides in Us by the word amen you
cannot live an obedient life outside of
this
desire of vision space 677 paragraph one
is to sue the word that Christ abides
and his followers
amen Pastor all right how would God know
if I have repented and how would God
know if I'm sinning how would God know
[Laughter]
that person must be joking God knows
everything
there's nothing hidden from God
knows if he repented he knows the
motives of your heart and mine so God
knows
because God will not punish you
illegally are you following me he has to
know what you've done or not done what I
have done or not done
he knows
God knows everything in here
all right
some of our churches are turning very
worldly drums not singing from hymnals
and going out for lunch after church
should we stay and lead by example or
find a church that is obedient find the
church that's obedient
listen to me the church will get worse
in the days of Solomon the entire nation
went into idolatry
and some Kings took the church the
entire nation into idolatry they were
still God's people
and so if you've seen many churches
going the way of the world do not be
shot be brokenhearted but is not a shock
it will get worse
um
you know in Ezekiel chapter 9 verse 4
put the mark upon the foreheads of the
men that sigh and cry for all the
Abominations that be done in the midst
there of this sigh and they cry why is
the church doing this why is the church
there
the church in my childhood is not the
church today
go to uh let's see go to hargai chapter
two hagiah chapter two
okay we were there earlier today
it's uh six or six I'll let you go in 10
minutes if not fewer
hagai chapter two
from verse one
in the seventh month
in the 1 and 20th year the month came
the word of the Lord by the prophet
haggai saying what speak now to the
ruvel the son of Shield Governor Judah
and to Joshua the son of Joseph the high
priest and to the resident of the people
saying now read with me who is left
among you come on that saw this house in
her first glory and how do you see it
now stop there were some old people who
came from uh captivity
and they could remember Solomon's Temple
you see so Hagia is saying is there
anyone among you who remembered that was
a glorious building
who is left among you that remember this
house in her first glory and how do you
see it now and as I look back on the
church I think to my who is there that
remembers when you could tell an
Adventist Church by the hymns that they
sang
who is left among you that can tell a
guest from a member are you following me
who is left among you that remembered
when people said good morning brothers
and sisters are not you guys
who is left among you that remembered
when people would send greetings from
the pulpit now they send shout outs
who is left among you that remembered
when Adventists could recite the Ten
Commandments
yes
how do you see the church now
who is left among you that remember the
days when Ellen White was respected
how is she treated now
who is left among you that can remember
that we're at this stage in this church
is still God's Church don't
misunderstand me and I love it it's the
right Church
but there's a lot of crazy things but
it's the right Church
but sometimes you have to decide will I
stay in this individual don't never
leave the seventh day out of the church
but find another one
so even Pasadena SDA or whomever
Altadena whatever but stay within the
Seventh Day Adventist Church
amen when the disciples Believe In
Christ in John chapter 6 Jesus said to
the twelve will ye also go away Peter
said Lord to whom shall we go thou Hast
the words of eternal life this church
has truth
some crazy behavior but it has doctoral
truth
that's what should hold you
amen and pray for the church
don't just criticize
criticism is not a spiritual gift
are you with me that's right pray for
the church
if you are focused on getting close to
Christ there are a lot of things you
might not see
but some people all they do is look at
what you're doing and then say well come
on drop that skirt another inch uh you
meet them in a supermarket they look
into a basket to see if there's any
chicken legs you know
and so you you're afraid to bump into
them in the supermarket because they're
checking you and then they decide you're
lost
because you have some salmon I'm not
promoting flesh I'm simply saying
there's an attitude of judgmentalism yes
but you uh is still God's search you see
and people change
if the behavior of a particular church
is distressing to you find another one
or if God convicts you to stay he may
work through your influence to change
the entire church amen
[Music]
God picks all look at what Saul did for
an entire oh churches all over Asia
Minor were raised it because of one man
next question all right and Genesis how
do I understand so the evening and the
morning were the first day doesn't today
start evening to evening yes that's what
the Bible says
from even unto even shall you celebrate
your Sabbath Leviticus 23 32 Mark 132 a
day begins at sunset
so what is this now
this is Sunday that's right biblically
it's Sunday
that's why when Paul preached until
midnight he was preaching on Sunday
night not not Sunday night and then into
Monday morning
in Acts 20. biblically we are now in
Sunday night
so yes a day begins at sunset in the
Bible that's right
next question all right is there a
difference of getting tied through
Adventist giving to our church compared
to giving cash to our church does God
have a preference if it all still goes
to the same place I am not sure I
understand the question giving tithe or
giving cash yes in other words the
Adventist giving is on the online on the
church's website and whether or not God
has a preference whether you give it
online or give it a cash at the church
give it to your local church
the local church has to be sustained
there is a theme in the Book of Judges
that runs this way every man did that
which was right in his own eyes we can't
have that the system the church presents
to us is give the tithe to the local
Storehouse the church then the church
takes it from there now no one will put
you in prison if you go online and give
it to a church in Nicaragua or something
but the system is given to the local
church now if you have some extra cash
you can do whatever you want
but the tithes are offering the local
church that's the system the church has
settled please respect it
and don't hate the church because the
conference president didn't do this or
that
when the Widow brought the little might
she gave it to church that Jesus knew
was corrupt
but he congratulated her when Jesus
healed there and I told you two nights
ago he healed the ten lepers he told
them go show yourselves to the priest
because only the priest could declare
them clean even though Jesus had healed
him
Christ respected the church I read when
was it I read do what the Pharisees said
don't do what they do
Christ's respected the church
no to return your tithe to the Pasadena
estia Church
people write me some time can I give the
tithe to you no
no way
I've done enough to make God angry with
me I don't need to add to it no way to
give it to me
all right next question I hope it's easy
whoa okay
can I remarry after a divorce I had a
divorce I did not agree with
did not sign court documents but was
defaulted by the court not aware of
adultery not not aware of adultery in
other words the situation was not uh
Ellen White says yeah there's one clear
reason in the Bible
for divorce that's adultery
she says the innocent person can remarry
the guilty person should not remarry
now the church may allow you to divorce
for all kinds of reasons but otherwise
said there's one clear purpose given in
the Bible for divorce that is adultery
the innocent person can remarry
the guilty person stays single
marriage is a serious thing you don't
jump into it and then jump out of it as
a workout
someone sent me a text yesterday I said
how are you how was hubby oh he left me
why I can't bear children
that's not a Biblical reason to get a
divorce
Malachi 2 verse 16 for the Lord the god
of Israel saved he hateth putting away
he hates divorce
your wife can't have children that's a
risk you take
so adultery is the clear biblical reason
for divorce the innocent party can
remarry
next question
the Bible States in Revelation in
another place Fountains of water what is
what is it referring to in the first
Angel's message I don't see that in
Exodus 20 11 describing God as Creator
what is Fountains of water
you can do your streams waterfalls
God made Heaven he made Earth he made
bodies of water and so we have Fountains
of water and revelation we have the sea
in a in Exodus just bodies of water and
they use different words this isn't
Expressions that's all
a function of water is not you know lava
it's water
so Revelation it starts about Fountains
of water streams waterfalls functions of
water The Fountains of the great deep
were broken up Genesis 7 verse 11 The
Fountains of the great deep were broken
up and the windows of Heaven were open
those are expressions
that talk about water
the sea Land The Fountains of waters yes
all right all right can you explain the
Three Angels message in a way that a new
believer May understand and be able to
preach it not right now
I'll have to charge you for that
amen amen by the way but every seven of
the Adventists must understand the Three
Angels messages amen how they connect in
Connect and their relation to the loud
Cry of Revelation 18. the loud cry is
for those in Babylon come out
that loud crying goes along the third
Angel's message that's the power that
will really enrage the world and enrich
Satan because it will start to have
results
and otherwise says the the the the the
results of that message are
proportionate to the enthusiasm with
which we preach it
you preach it as though you don't care
the results are minimal you preachers if
a matter of Life on death the results
are different
first question
I don't quite understand this question
but I'll ask your shirt anyway does a
Layman have any power in the church they
go to if that church tells stories but
do not use scriptures does a Lemon have
any Authority yeah
that's the question okay if you're a
baptized member of the church you have a
right to pre-approach the pastor or the
head Elder and make your concerns known
yes you have that right
yeah
yes you have that right okay as a
baptized member of the church you can
say I have you may ask to address the
church board
that's your right
you don't have to go flaunting you're
right every time the Passover is a blue
suit you want to address the board but
no but if you think there's a concern
regarding what's coming from the pulpit
yes you can say look Pastor I want to
talk to you head Elder I want to talk to
you
I have a great concern about what's
coming from this building
great concern and they listen
whether they agree or not is not the
point but you have the right to make
your concern known
pray to God first then go
because Jesus said before you take the
beam out of some the moat out of
someone's eye what should you do take
the beam out of yours that's the law of
criticism is there a beam in your eye
while you're trying to take the mort out
of mind so we do that
a young man asked me in some country
should we quit we should criticize the
government I said no there's a condition
for that cleanse the church then go try
to clean up the government
mm-hmm you get all the time stealing out
of the church all the working on Sabbath
all the mixed marriages all the
fornication all the alcohol the secrets
get all of that out then go criticize
the government because the corrupt
church is more corrupt than a corrupt
government
have mercy
the government doesn't claim to know the
Bible the church claims to know Divine
standards a corrupt church is more
corrupt than a corrupt government
next question
okay uh Satan has studied the secrets of
the Laboratories of Nature and uses all
his power to control the elements as far
as God allows uh-huh great controversy
88 and also page 589 paragraph one the
question is can we reason that Satan is
more powerful than ever than ever yeah
he is more clever than ever yes but his
degree of power has not increased his
skillfulness has increased yes and it is
he largely who sends storms and
hurricanes and causes Wars otherwise
said the devil calls his world so that
people can kill each other
um
you know we have this thing this thing
called acts of God a flood is an act of
God a landslide an earthquake nor their
acts of Satan
but God gets to blame
the Bible calls it the prince of the
power of the air
mm-hmm powerful being
nice question this is the last question
all right God is good
[Laughter]
the question is why are so many SDA
Church pastors not using the spirit of
Prophecy
Ellen White's writings what are they
afraid of They're Not Afraid some of
them do not have they do not appreciate
the value of the testimonies and they
may honestly not appreciate it
by God's grace they may come to the
place where they realize oh I have been
depriving the Church of a tremendous
Gold Mine of spiritual wisdom some of
them deliberately undermine Ella why
some of them don't believe in her as a
prophet at all
have gone to church where I was told we
don't quote from Ellen White
I said can I quote he said yes but we
don't
so I did I was in a certain field in a
certain part of the world
and a pester in that conference told me
that the local conference circulated a
letter requesting that Minister signed
to say I will not quote Ellen White
vanderbolden
and that particular Pastor refused to do
it
it's a very serious thing it's not
strange did not the Jews kill the
prophets
that's right
we're killing Ellen White it's no
different
God's people are killing God's prophet
well the ultimate killing of a prophet
was the killing of Jesus
and the Roman said I find no fault I
find no fault I find no fault the Romans
said let this man go the church said
kill him
so it's no surprise if the church will
kill Jesus they'll kill Ellen White but
let me recommend to you in the presence
of a holy God expose your mind to the
writings of Ellen White
expose your children to the writings of
Ellen White your lives will change some
young man wrote me two days ago
and spiritually this and spiritually
that and going down the prayer for me
many times people don't eat prayers just
need to make a decision
I told him read steps to Christ chapter
5.
he wrote me the next day he said I had
never seen it I've read the book before
I had never seen it that way
immediately there was a change I told
him to follow up with chapter six he
read it he wrote back I I want to thank
you about two years ago someone wrote me
my life is on the decline spiritually I
have no desire for God I told her
confess your sins read steps to Christ
chapter 5.
the person wrote back
I have experienced a change
true story
Ellen White was a prophet
as much as Isaiah or Jeremiah
her writings don't qualify to be in the
Bible but the gift she has was a very
gift Isaiah had
and her gift was given to her for this
church not the whole world for this
church to keep this church off the rocks
of era
um
Satan knows that so Satan gets into us
and tries to break our confidence in the
writings of Allah and she has told us
those who deny her writings will
eventually deny the Bible because the
source of authority is the same the
spirit of God
he also says those who believe in her
testimonies will not be deceived in the
time of trouble
please
if God is my witness make time for the
writings of his servant sent to be a
blessing to this church
that's it Pastor one more yes one more
almost overlooked it it was a statement
first but it ended in a question and
this person is asking for prayer Pray
for my sons yes they grew up in the
church but they don't go anymore to the
church and then it is maybe because I
was not converted completely so I'm sure
this is they're wondering if they're at
fault yes for there's her son's not
coming to church this may be hard but
parents you are to a large degree
responsible for the spiritual condition
of your children
because they come into the world as an
empty slate
and they are affected by the influences
around them particularly the home
so if you have no time for your child
you're pursuing a career or money or
whatever and the child grows up
spiritually Twisted yes you bear some
responsibility
it's not a pleasant message to give but
it's absolutely true
no child comes into the world and raises
itself
the word of God is what is required to
raise a chance so Solomon says train up
a child to train takes time and in
commenting on this verse Ella white
writes Solomon did not say tell a child
she said Solomon said train a child and
she puts a train in italics
freeing a child
that takes sacrifice and time
but we serve a God who forgives are you
with me
and some of us as parents may need to
sit down and say to our children
I am to blame
forgive me
forgive me I am to blame
let's see what we can do from this point
on I am to blame forgive me
Children See hypocrisy in the home and
they say nothing because they're
children when they reach the age of
responsibility they leave the church
because they see one thing at church
another thing at home
and children can children can tolerate
anything except hypocrisy and
inconsistent they can tolerate poverty
homelessness not inconsistency in the
parents
yes they cannot handle that
but With God all things are possible
there's no hopeless case with God if
someone is willing to say father help me
to salvage this situation because God is
not willing that your child should
perish
so when you pray to God you're praying
to God who wants to save how many people
everybody he wants to I said he wants to
thank you very much God bless you God
bless you Pastor thank you if ever I
come across your mind wherever you are
simply say Lord put your words in that
man's mouth
stay here pastor
have you enjoyed this revival
truly a blessing in past Escape we want
to thank you for committing to come to
spend this time with us and we know you
travel the world we know you're very
busy but how many of you enjoyed this so
much you like to see this happen next
year
amen amen we will reach out to him to
see if he's able to do that but Pastor
Keith we want to pray for you at this
time please please I want to pray for
you and I like for you the the
congregation if you guys would kneel and
we can kneel here on the platform and
pray for Pastor Keith
and I'd like for you to pray silently in
your heart's form as well
father God
oh Lord Oh Lord thank you for
remembering us this week Revival
thank you for your blessings upon us by
giving us the opportunity to hear your
voice from on high
we praise your holy name for all the
blessings you've given us from the day
we were born into this reverent moment
and we come by Faith Lord especially
asking for forgiveness of our sins our
trespasses and iniquities against you
Lord may your spirit Reign and be poured
out upon us all but right now God we're
lifting up your man's servant Pastor
Keith you have dedicated his life a
living sacrifice to be one who would
speak your words throughout the world
he have given up so much and have
sacrificed so much time and effort and
energy in proclaiming the unadulterated
Three Angels messages we pray for the
anointing upon him even more we pray
that you will protect him as he goes to
and fro throughout this world may your
angels that excel in strength protect
him night and day be with his wife his
family Lord protect them in their home
each entryway Lord with your angels we
pray Lord for the blessings upon him and
now even the unspoken request that's in
his heart please fulfill that and oh god
of Heaven We forever give you the praise
honor and glory and once again pour out
your spirit upon him like never before
that he will continue to go forth
through this world sharing the truth
unadulterated we thank you for the
blessing of allowing him to be with us
this week thank you o God and keep us
and as we leave this place oh God give